[Music]
follow me you see something special all
the world is made of stories and all of
those stories are right here with bottle
to all the stars for you this evening my
young friends in fairy tales love
inspires you to be noble and courageous
but in real life love is just an
all-purpose excuse for selling paper to
teaching theories of Mike on Saturday
but one day can change everything that's
the fantasy that's a fairy tale grace
it's not real life and it's not real
love real love is this obligation
if you want to do commuters say that
one thing that happened at the very very
very beginning of time
[Music]
there's nothing in our service system
can't help us now you need to tell me
what your plan is to save the world
into a movie now is one of the most
brilliant weird and unusual American
documentary films I've seen in a long
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
extinction are you telling me the fate
of a billion people is in the hands of
his criminal
[Music]
oh wait no what are you doing why do I
try to catch me try and kiss you this is
the most uncomfortable fistfight i've
ever been in
[Music]